previously on raft guys you gotta see
this it's cool come on over here let me
show you my city all right robot oh
shoot to me yeah he knows who the real
boss is uh the owner of this place oh
wow oh it's the bear stuck in the man's
nose penis all right I guess the
illusion of this being our first time
here is lost oh I see a bear nose penis
painting I see that I don't have my
machete oh do you have a machete I might
have a men's Getty for you I'm going to
go out and get more water move the boat
around I open the door I don't know how
to drive it so no problem yes beyond
your company
hey wait there's our boat our boat's
right here you're the one in charge of
food Mark no no no no that's someone
else a mysterious fourth person who has
been hiding away on our boat
I have one more bowl of soup Wade
it was delicious do you drink
you want some soup oh I hate you oh
that's great I found titanium is that
important
pass right away do you need soup soup so
you get the titanium right you get here
you got 13. for the soup first silly all
right
soon
hope you'll hope you like it
[Music]
and you know
oh what are you gonna do look at me
angrily oh no no no no no no no oh no
did you just get out did I got out dude
it did it did happen it's okay
unbelievable it was unbelievable yes I
can hardly believe it I saw it coming
explain me your secret ways of your
foreskin side oh you're pissed off every
robot I must know where the Scrolls of
your order ah the Elder Scrolls I
thought you were gonna yeah I thought
you're gonna ask him about his mystical
scrotes everyone's favorite video game
series The Elder Scrolls
[Music]
um I feel like we're missing something
I'm in a new building that no one had
been in previously
that was just amazing doing probably the
important stuff we're supposed to be
doing probably
[Music]
I'm just saying I'm not bragging I am
just saying probably I'm the only one
doing anything that matters right now
man you're just saying voice sounds a
lot like bragging I would have thought
though I I mean that's my bad that's my
mistake yeah I guess you just never
listened to me that well huh yeah I I
don't well I'm going to successfully do
the zipline thing
you telling yourself that but oh my
elevator in my building just being
bonged many boys coming up to uh coming
up to Big Boy land
no
no fourth
passenger on the boat
the mysterious fourth uh member of the
Discord when we record our hit podcast
distractible
distractible that sounds delightful this
is probably gonna kill me
I made it I made it
glass and copper
this was all for glass and copper Big
Win buddy Big Win wasn't that really all
for the experience of the journey
yeah oh I know what this is about
[Laughter]
it was right in front of me all along
all along
oh wait no it's not
okay he's in front of me all along
I actually know what this is about yeah
wait a minute no it's what's about
you got it buddy enunciate enunciate no
what what's about that's so much better
your subs are growing yeah that's good I
feel powerful yes yes more more uh super
scrotes yeah it's going down [__] it's
going up oh I see the way wait a minute
it was in front of us all along
but the secret
God why didn't I see it sooner what I am
getting the content
it's me that succeeded cool oh cool okay
excellent okay if we could if I can I
can you send that to me no I work in
very high uh bid rate video footage
could never send it never oh okay yeah
that sounds terrible yes yes it is
incredibly difficult to work with but
how many tokis do we have like a
thousand
yeah probably probably foul probably
good ultimate yeah like a thou you
thinking the foul like a wrap hey guys
we have 16 tokens yes look at though how
could you tell T T
we have 15 tapes 16 token four key card
eight berries one recorder one
mechanical part
ah
[Music]
are you just are you spending our tokens
no I'm in a building how do I get out of
here Mark I found your recipe first I
swear to God there was a way or here it
is I'm gonna make the jump I'm gonna
make it
I did not make the jump I think I'm
about to play the same game that you oh
weird
chin Spain weird teeth chin stain I
don't see that painting either
did you make it Bob
um
I'm not on the ground
okay hello I'm sorry what is this that I
have a bowl of coconut chicken oh
do you have oh my God that's such good
food oh you needed soup still I have no
I stole something from Mark I didn't
give him what I promised in exchange I
have two bowls of soup and I'm ready to
be hurt again he's looking at masochist
no he just likes to see if his body can
take it yeah that one which whichever
one how the hell do we get up there I
hate everything no no no no
no don't hate there's a building that
has an 11th floor and a 13th floor and
it looks like the 13th floor was not
very well explored by y'all whoever was
up here who says y'all who says y'all
yeah who says y'all me
stop it get some help I'll come back now
you here oh hey guess who has two
Titanium Ore I guess he has no soup this
man oh oh hey friend up there on the
building I see you I know I'm trying
but that's not high enough
how do we get up
higher we have to get over to the
balcony of this one that is a cross but
I'm like how do we do that right how do
we do that indeed yeah it seems like it
should be fairly obvious but it's got to
be like a uh zipline
thingamabob but there's a big zip line
up here on like these really tall
buildings do you have as are you do you
see any zip lines that go to the center
rod with actually yeah I think I'm close
to it well yeah the one that I think
might lead to the no the one the one I'm
on leads to it but we got to get to the
one across from this
um okay I think I better want to cross
from it actually yeah I see is there a
way to get in that building and take it
up because that would be the one is it
worth killing the big scary monster rats
they got me I mean they give you meat oh
thought I was dead but turns out I'm
alive
uh why is there no way to get into
building three but there's also no way
to get
okay I'm fine I was just clearing my
throat
oh hey Mark hello oh hi Mark hello
welcome wow you must have many Subs many
more now
wow very impressive have you found a way
thank you does this work for everyone
yes yes
what a girthy subscriber base you have
yeah I am in disbelief
excellent Subs
oh my God Bob you can't do that you
can't go up a zip line you don't know
what if I do it what if I give it a
running start
watch watch watching
huh ah okay oh wow that was uh did I do
it I think I just saw a man die how's
your ankles
not bad
good to hear my left arm is numb after
sneezing is that good that's not good no
oh boy
why do I get into the sky but it's the
ways
well your left arm going nubbins is uh
is a concerning thing um that's okay
it's just from sneezing uh-huh you know
we think we didn't we solve this once
yes I think probably very stupid and
easy
um maybe it wasn't us I'm pretty sure we
just cheated though when we solved it
maybe our stunt doubles solved it maybe
the mysterious fourth person did it have
we cut the tape of all the places that
needed tape cutting I think so the ones
that I've seen I cut several okay so I
see broken glass
to get to the wire that we need to get
to oh hey what's up look
I'm taking it the elevator doesn't go to
that floor though I don't think it does
go up to that floor because I I am
pretty sure
the
the zip line below it is the highest you
can go in that building I think
oh God I'm gonna run out of water
oh wait no oh God I can't Sprint anymore
and I just sprinted into the deep dark
oh God it's dark it's all closing in on
me oh you go back to the water to use
the tape yeah that's what I thought but
I'm dying and for some reason soup
doesn't give any liquid oh wow I am slow
uh ain't my guy water lots of water yeah
man I'm having flashbacks do I get some
water
I don't know where you are man where are
you I love some water dude let's play on
the raft I'm looking at the the big
statue
a lot of water on the raft oh you're on
the Middle where the statue is I know
where that is
I can't get there in time probably
though oh wait it has the watermelon and
he's eating it in front of me yeah I
needed water that looks really juicy you
know it's pretty pretty rude for someone
who gave you soup man yeah it took a lot
to get that soup from you I gave it to
you for free I didn't rub the water in
your face you know it was Bob who
mentioned the fact that I just happened
to be eating the watermelon
good
[Applause]
shouting
dumb question it wasn't Mark kind of
right
don't we need to go use the tape
I think if we use the tape I'm being
killed oh dear me
supplier killed oh
you need water and a rescue
whatever Marcus
I'm at the Gold statue where are you I
wandered into an alley and I died
oh I got shanked by a robot that's a
really interesting choice that you made
Mark oh volley my friends had rescued me
I see a dead body on the ground is that
you it might be me do you hear the
Wailing of the Damned shut up oh okay
thank you hey shut your holes
if you come back you bring some extra
water
oh what a rest that was delightful
feel better I do I do I feel the point
of being able to come out here to this
spot that would be a point
you're really asking the Deep questions
but all right
what do we got
that'll do
okay why do I hear you drinking water
from the top of the building
I know and I hear you from the top of
this building with water
man that is in good water
all right tons of water yeah you were
right but but honestly
where are we supposed to go what is did
you make it to the tape I'm gonna go
back down to the tape I think I had like
a something in my brain told me oh yeah
isn't isn't there something that's like
connected to that like that'll open up
another door for some reason maybe maybe
I'll let you guys know it's dark down
there so I'm
I might die but I know my friends will
come rescue me
for a price
it's a price
um I don't know it depends how desperate
one tungsten take it or leave it
or Titanium or whatever it is I have all
of that yeah take it or leave it Deal's
a deal Shake on it shake leave it why
would I take I've already got it Jake
I can't take take wieners then let's do
this
grip on that thing
thank you
what a power move
I see that you taped the wires Mark I
taped one of them
oh is there multiple I think there are
multiples
oh the electricity
I take it's still doing the electricity
that's a little surprising you know
what's hidden there is a number that
number you put on the elevator once you
put on the elevator you can go to the
floor you need did you just look it up
no I'm just guessing
you don't think he is I think he looked
I did not look it up I have literally
been running around this whole time if
I'm right it's because either I somehow
remember solving it last time or I
guessed right
I think you looked it up
did anything change up on the surface
Wade
no I'm trying to find the wrap so I can
get water too wait the electricity
stopped hey
I
died
okay an electric purifier that sounds
dope
we can have water
I heard somebody complaining about that
so that's probably good
maybe I don't know it might be that
mysterious fourth person
oh
Tarik
ah shoot a Turk swastika you trust your
heart to Lipitor this is an ad
[Music]
I don't know
I was just thinking about all these like
numb left arm thing maybe I should
consult my doctor yeah you are you all
right are you uh I'm fine thank you
still numb no no it came back pretty
quick okay well the elevator door is not
open so that didn't change
birthday
happy birthday to you ladies and
gentlemen
I have uh incredible news
uh-huh my God I am incredible
okay I am stunning get to the point I am
just outstanding is anyone there to
witness my glory no anybody around
nearby want to look up nobody's close
some kind of very important building
that all of you are I'm gonna whip when
you see me
I don't see you I don't see where I
thought I would so now I'm confused look
up on me and weep yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes
oh God if I had messed that jump up
that would have been I have to be honest
I thought I'd buy you in a specific
place and I'm not and now I'm really
confused all right hold on well we're
almost there
but he said look and witness me what he
meant was I'm working on it though don't
look good no I meant what I said if you
had looked at a certain angle in a small
window you would have seen a certain
point of view I'm looking at the one
thing that I know that we need to do
right now so
all right well
am I looking at the right place hold on
wait hold on I'm not ready I don't look
I'm holding on don't look I am my
goodness
Chris could not be matched yes yes my
greatness oh God
ah yeah yes yes yes
watch Witness
holy [__] I got that one on camera oh
yes
a sample of my True Glory what a
triumphant zipline sir
I thought there was an invisible wall on
the platter there for a second please
don't fall off of that I'm begging you I
did not I'm sending the elevator
foreign
up down what am I doing with it
I don't know push all the buttons man
see what happens I'm sending the I'm
bringing the elevator down
and I'm opening the front look at all
these things we learned that was a fast
elevator holy crap
these recipes
I researched the titanium
oh hell yeah
I don't know
which I don't know which floor was the
correct floor
what is all of this crap
oh no we need two we need two
look Wade I've gotten all the way to the
top of the thing
oh
I was gonna wait I was gonna win well I
see a bird
okay hey we're all doing stuff Bob this
is for you
a bowl of soup I shall cherish it [__]
large storage large storage blueprint
freaking cabinets and [__] Bro oh my God
emergency
clay Bowl that's crazy that Mark gave me
one of those hey guys we need um
we need a code
code whoa Mark we're outside the Dome up
here what about try Resident Evil Code
Veronica see if that works oh we do need
a code
um I just got invited to play raft by
somebody else thank you for the invite
are you just guessing codes now I'm
trying to remember what the number I
always use for everything is
2702 right
give me what your passwords live on
live on recording no it's my Tesla
referral code
oh
Mark 2702 although that was your number
in space jam with markiplier it is okay
because it's the same Easter egg I
solved it why is your hook on the ground
why isn't yours
thank you all right so how do we get a
code yeah how do we get a code Wade uh
wait what is it I don't [__] know
well we were really busy accomplishing
this together what were you doing with
your time uh getting the titanium
cleaning up inventory a bit
inventory it's like a waste of time to
me well let's hop back on the boat and
dump the [__] that we have I guess Wade
yeah that's me have you seen a code uh
uh try 39. wait a minute was it in the
note that we just got yeah hey did you
look at the note we just got one no wait
I just
how about you do the honors of whatever
so the code's not in there but the the
answer to the code is in there ah I see
and that is that there must be numbers
on these different buildings there's a
picture of a I'm not sure what that is I
think that's a hamburger I think that's
a scissors and I think that's a life
preserver and they have Road street
lights to them right right one's a
sleepy so it's the in the burger place
the barbershop and then
I don't know we could just guess the
last one Burgers is eight okay eight
I'm not going to remember it but I'll
try my best I believe in you okay
burgers
[Music]
the arcade is fours the arcade one of
them four arcade oh maybe that's like
the virtual reality maybe it's a virtual
reality helmet not like a mask
four so that's four yeah that's okay
yeah arcade is four Burgers is eight
arcade is four Burgers is eight arcade
is four Burgers is eight ah here comes
another one oh yeah
the floating fashion is five oh that's a
three that's a three nope that's a three
yes four eight something five
three
three sir
three I feel as though this last one can
probably be guessed at
um I think we should do it right oh wait
I see it it's over here
four eight four three oh wait no no no
no this is the arcade never mind why
robot oh here it is it's one
[Music]
I'll get the POV of outside
right did you find a button for the
elevator no
all right
excellent I was gonna get in position
for the position
I was not in position
we do it
oh boy good wrath just get hit by a hunk
of burning metal no
I'm going for it
that's a long swim I misjudged this is
steep guys only we had a rest don't
worry I'm with you this is probably fine
wait bring the wrap all right bring the
raft Wade yeah wait where's the left
around it's where we parked it probably
excellent I could make that swim I'm
with you brother I'm making the swim
he's with you brother are you with me
brother
yes I know that brother's with me Wade
brother oh God no brother Wade not even
close to with you brother Wade sister
wife Wade are you with us I am not
wait
I'm going to get to get the raft
don't forget to raise the anchor and
also do all the other stuff about
driving the raft I've never driven it
don't know how
it's real easy-ish don't worry brother
I'm here with you yes I'm just scouting
the perimeter brother yes I see I see
the whole of entrance I'm waiting
no shark
he was afraid of our teamwork and bond
we share and brotherness raising anchor
did you go inside I went in sorry I
thought there was no way for the other
brother to be here oh hey there's
someone here
what
Hey where's the steering wheel at
there's someone here they went for a
ride well at least they're strapped in
yeah you okay uh uh Elaine it's good
that when we randomly launched the
bridge into space this person was like
man I better be sitting here fully
strapped in case yeah boys
it's on the third the third floor of the
poop deck
it's in the studio apartment on the top
of our building raft come on now
excellent Mark is just inside doing all
the stuff this lady's saying things I
don't know but though
uh-huh I should probably turn the
engines on huh
important part of it yep I called them
Direction I called dibs on
what
divs on a lane you heard I don't think
that's out
no being Elaine oh sure embodying Elaine
um my name is James Tully James Tully
not the guy from Avatar
yes our city was built on a purely
theoretical basis
using engines that are very going
forward very fast held together by The
Sweat and Tears of our crew but we were
never sustained oh we got another uh
code Verona when the rafters arrived my
pretty one oh my pretty one there's
literally nothing else here it's kind of
empty to the waves
it was just like a code a water tank a
blueprint and that was who does an
idiots who used to run the world and
this guy's still talking apparently
um
yeah I thought the boat would be here by
now uh we're coming full speed we yeah
me and the shark that's eating our boat
I feel like you're go the wrong way on
my screen
yeah I see a shaping a distance filling
away into the ocean instead of driving
toward where we are right now no no I
wouldn't leave you
huh would you no no wait
trust me
wait wait definitely coming
we're a team never leave you
we are we are a team yeah that's an
important part of this is that we're a
team yeah teamwork and as a team draft
is is getting is not getting bigger no
no it is you know I can see the pile of
trash that you would be in front of and
it's kind of like drawing a line away
kind of away from us don't worry boys
oh the rest is maybe getting a little
bigger maybe well on my way
wouldn't leave you all right the more
you say it the more I believe you I'm
definitely on my way well you're
definitely getting closer now so I feel
like yes I will yeah okay cool yeah he's
coming mark okay good good yeah it looks
like it never was it never was never was
never was coming or never was to be
never was huh never was coming away
yeah he's got he's coming over here he's
coming he's crazy
okay he's gonna reverse it he backing it
up you're gonna you're gonna you're
gonna butter this Landing if you find a
good parking spot or you just are you
just looks very full and look at him
looking uh-huh
yeah that's he's coming excellent It's
coming fast
oh hey
wow I feel like he's gonna uh crash into
us now no no well uh uh uh dropping
anchor
whoa wow
all right
hell yeah nicely done always believed in
you everything
Wham oh I forgot you don't actually need
to bring the blueprints that's dumb oh
well well hey electric purifier and also
large storage is now ours whoa you can
also make all those things that require
titanium oh and there's one titanium
Ingot inside this Barrel we need four I
don't know how we get more of them but
we only got two oh
how do we get more I don't know but I do
think I need to cut here well it seems
like a good point we got a new
destination oh no
it's the Sharknado oh yeah it's back it
followed us
oh it's not even sharks it's hentai NATO
oh god oh
no more
you